welcome to the show everybody
congratulations on on getting to the
weekend alive we're hunkering down for
some snow this weekend around these
parts and I'm really looking forward to
two to it I'm looking forward to the
familiar parenting ritual which every
parent is familiar with where you know
you spend seventy five minutes getting
the kids bundled up in their 19
different layers and and and you get the
boots on and everything else and
invariably you're always missing like
one glove and one hat and then you go
looking for it and someone has to wear
mismatched gloves they start crying
about that because they want gloves that
match but then they're upset because the
Hat is too cold or too itchy or whatever
and then you get them all bundled up all
padded you know like they're like
they're a glass vase that you're about
to ship FedEx across the country and
then of course one of them has to pee as
soon as you get them bundled so you get
them unbundled and they pee and then you
get them re-- bundled and then and then
you go outside and as soon as you get
outside one of them takes the gloves off
and starts crying because their hands
are cold and then another one falls
face-first face-planting in the snow and
starts crying because of that and you're
laughing because it's kind of funny and
then you sled for maybe ninety two
seconds before everybody wants to go
inside because they're bored and they're
cold and then now you're yelling at them
I'm like no you're gonna have fun we are
having fun get down here and make a snow
angel this is fun this is family time
have fun damn it but and now everyone's
crying including yourself and so you go
back inside
and you take off all the clothes and
then you do it again two hours later but
at least your wife gets the picture of
the 45 seconds the 45 second period
where everybody was momentarily happy
your your wife gets the picture of that
and puts it on Facebook with a caption
like snow day with the fam and then the
good thing is that every other parent
can see the picture and can get angry at
their own kids for ruining the snow day
and wondering why their kids can't be
more like your kids who according to
photographic evidence are apparently
angels so it's um it's a lot of fun
though honestly and I'm I am looking
forward to it so um I want to start with
this just because it annoys me and
that's how I decide what I talked about
on the show if you haven't noticed
there's a story on NPR
dot-com right now with the headline
canceling student debt is easier than it
sounds
Wow easier than it sounds great senator
Elizabeth Warren has pledged to cancel
up to fifty thousand dollars of debt for
ninety five percent of student loan
borrowers if she is elected president
reading from the article now senator
Bernie Sanders has proposed an even more
generous plan if he's elected generous
is one way but it's very easy I don't
know if I would use the word generous
when someone comes up with a plan that
doesn't involve their own money it's
very easy to be generous with other
people's money that's very generous it's
like if if if Jim comes up to me and
asks if he can steal money from Bob and
I say yeah sure go ahead
is that me being generous or is that me
just not giving a crap about Bob both
are the article says both are bold
controversial pitches that would have a
hard time making it through a divided
Congress but on Tuesday Warren announced
that she would use a little-known
shortcut and wouldn't need Congress as
president she says she would cancel the
debts of tens of millions of student
borrowers all on her own it turns out
she's probably right Warren wrote in the
statement our country's experiment with
debt financed education went terribly
wrong instead of getting ahead millions
of student loan borrowers are barely
treading water I mean I don't know if we
can say it went horribly wrong when the
problem is that people took out loans
and are now expected to repay them I
don't know if that's necessarily go
things going wrong I agree we have a
problem
and and and there's there's an issue
here but I don't know if you could say
it went wrong this is very similar
Democrats do this a lot with things so
it's very similar to when somebody talks
about accidentally getting pregnant that
something went wrong and I ended up
pregnant
no nothing went wrong it actually went
exactly right actually the the sexual
act that you participated in it did
exactly what it's sort of supposed to do
so when you take out a loan and you sign
on the dotted line and then and then the
person who gave you the loan comes back
and says we want that money now you
can't say what something's gone wrong
here something's gone terribly wrong
back to the article about 43 million
student borrowers owe the government 1.5
trillion dollars and until now the
department has only suffered student
loan offered student loan forgiveness or
cancellation to borrowers who meet
certain criteria
but the plan anyway I'll summarize the
rest of not gonna read the whole thing
the warrant says that there might be
some sort of loophole that she can use
where she could just on her own stroke
of the pen as a president and get rid of
a lot of that a lot of that debt but at
the very end we get a question offered
by Adam Looney of the urban Brookings
Tax Policy Center says that Warren's
plan would disproportionately benefit
the wealthy with the bottom 20% of
borrowers by income reaping just four
percent of the savings as such Looney
asks why are those who went to college
more deserving of a than those who did
it that's a good question
and we'll get back to that question in a
second but here's another question why
are we using the phrase student loan
cancellation or student loan forgiveness
see that's not really what's being
proposed we're not talking about
cancellation we're talking about
transfer the debt will be transferred
from the people who took the loan out to
people who did not that's what this is
and that's the word we should be using
student loan transfer
so the only problem of course for
advocates of this idea is that student
loan transfer sounds unjust and kind of
crazy mean it sounds crazy when you put
it that way right so say that okay we're
gonna take the loan from people who took
out the loan and for someone who didn't
take out the loan to pay it that sounds
crazy and that's because it is now of
course Bernie and and and Elizabeth
Warren have both claimed that they can
transfer the whole burden to the
ultra-wealthy and they'll make the
so-called ultra-wealthy pay for it the
issue with that first of all of course
is that I'm not dumb enough to believe
that it's only going to be the so-called
ultra wealthy carrying the burden here
because it never works out that way it
never has in the past that's the first
problem second is that the ultra wealthy
are not anymore responsible for a
stranger student debt than I am I don't
maybe it's not popular to care that much
about the ultra wealthy but
you know the reason I don't want to have
to pay back someone else's student loans
it's because I didn't take out the loan
why should I have to pay it it's not my
loan
and you know if I had a hundred million
dollars in the bank I would feel the
same way
yes I could I could quote afford it more
but why should I have to do that
any more than I should have to you know
it's why should I I didn't take out the
loan it would it would be my same
argument see my argument right now for
why I as a non millionaire should not
have to pay back other people student
loans my argument is not that I can't
afford it
my argument is it's not my loan
so I shouldn't have to and that argument
doesn't change no matter how much money
I have or don't have
but now Warren is talking about erasing
debt with the stroke of a pen all on her
own again though if you think that's
gonna be free I mean if she can even
legally do it which I don't at all think
she can but if you think the federal
government is just gonna eat that
trillion dollar loss and not raise taxes
to to compensate for it then I don't
know what to tell you I really don't
know what to tell you
that's that is that is several steps
beyond merely gullible if you think the
guy with the federal government is just
gonna say alright never mind you don't
the payback a trillion dollars well yeah
no no no big deal no big deal we don't
need it what does the federal government
ever said that
okay you think the IRS has ever said
that to somebody owes them taxes you
think the IRS is gonna say you know it
yeah you know what forget it actually
nevermind it's okay no no it's fine it
really is fine it doesn't work that way
it does not work with that way with the
government it has never worked that way
with any government ever
that's not how government's function so
again what we're talking about here one
way or another is the transfer of debt
taking the debt away from the people who
sign on the dotted line and agreed to it
and putting it on the shoulders of
people who weren't in that meeting
didn't sign that document and haven't
reaped the benefits of it now here's
another thing to consider about this
student loan forgiveness stuff and going
back to going back to the question that
was posed at the end of the NPR article
because it's hard for me to see this
every time I hear about student loan
forgiveness
it's hard for me to see it as anything
other than welfare for the upper-class
that's what it appears to be because
it's not like college graduates are the
only ones with debt that they're dealing
with
it's not like they're the only ones who
have large monthly payments they have to
make the only difference is that college
graduates tend to come from higher
social classes and they have higher
future income earning potential
if not higher income right now which
many of them do so here's my point if
we're talking about waving a magic wand
and erasing debt if that's actually
possible to do which it isn't but if it
is if it were in this in this
hypothetical situation and we have that
magic wand or Elizabeth Warren has that
magic one
why not wave it in the direction of
lower class or poorer people you know
right raise it up
wave it in the direction of blue-collar
workers and middle and lower class
people
there's a trillion dollars or so worth
of collective outstanding student debt
1.5 trillion dollars okay and we're told
we can get rid of that
well there's also a trillion or so
dollars worth of outstanding car loan
debt
not everybody has or needs a degree but
most people have and need a car
especially middle class and blue-collar
workers because they're less likely to
work in this to live in the city where
you can get away with not having a car
they're gonna be out in rural areas or
in the suburbs or they're commuting to
work and most of them are paying three
or four hundred dollars a month for
further a car to pay off their car loan
and that's an enormous burden for most
people all of the economic benefits of
releasing people of their student loan
payments and this is the argument we
hear that well think about the the
economic boom of telling people they
don't have to pay back their student
loan debt now they've got all this extra
money that they can go and spend on
something else which is already a
problem by the way we won't get into but
you know it's a there's a fundamental
problem with this consumer driven
economy where where it's not like we're
saying oh you know we could free them of
the debt and then they could save the
money for the future no no we don't want
them to do that we want them to go and
spend it so it's you know they're gonna
end up just as broke as they were before
we need you to go out and just buy more
stuff rather than wasting your money to
pay back your student loan debt wasted
on something else wasted on consumer
electronics or something like that you
know go on a shopping spree but if
that's the argument for so-called
forgiving student loan debt then I can
make the exact same argument for
forgiving car car loan debt
and again a car is a practical item that
people actually need unlike a liberal
arts degree which in so many cases
ultimately is useless
there are a lot of people who are
sitting around essentially with their
with their with their college degree
basically stashed in the garage not
using it there aren't a lot of people
who have who have their car stashed away
and aren't using it unless they live in
the city but most people they they have
a car and they use it every day they
need it
point being y favor wealthier people who
bought a worthless thing over poorer
people who bought a necessary thing what
kind of system is that is that justice
is that fairness we're gonna say we need
to forgive their debt because they're
wealthier and they didn't need the thing
they bought what how does that make any
sense
how about credit card debt again around
a trillion dollars outstanding a credit
card debt in this country again massive
economic benefits from freeing people of
that burden again that is a debt shared
by middle and lower class people again
it's a you know credit card is I'm not
gonna call it a necessary item
technically speaking but it's certainly
useful for a lot of people and it proves
more useful than a college degree which
in so many cases is not useful at all
this would be you know not welfare for
the upper class this would be more of an
egalitarian welfare for people all
across the social spectrum now you might
say well where does this end cancel card
debt cancel credit card debt cancel
student loan debt cancel mortgage debt
we didn't talk about that yet you could
say where does it end and where does
this money come from and how does this
work how can you just absolve everyone
of all of their financial commitments
and what about the institutions that
issued these loans I know it's not
popular to stick up for them these days
and it's it's much more fun to demonize
them and maybe they deserve to be
demonized in so many cases but the fact
is you know how is it fair or just to
just come in after the fact after these
loans have been agreed to and and the
the forms have been filled out and to
just make it and to nullify all of these
agreements that were made yes exactly
see that objection that anyone would
have to cancelling car loan payments and
credit card payments and mortgages
I agree where does it end
good question you see if you're arguing
for for forgiving student loan debt you
can either admit that the middle and
lower classes deserve some relief too
and then say sure let's forgive all of
that debt also but then you run into the
problem of the sheer insanity of this
picture it becomes so large and so vast
and we're just forgiving all the debt
and that's a problem or you can say
which appears to be what most people are
saying if not directly this is the
answer the answer appears to be well no
this should be an isolated one-time
special thing and and and we're gonna do
it for college graduates but then you
have to explain why college graduates in
the upper class should be the
beneficiaries of the isolated one-time
special thing
why not the lower class if we are gonna
do it as a one-time thing for one group
of people why not make it for the for
the carpet or the credit card or
mortgage now they're the outstanding
collective debt is I think more like 8
trillion rather than one but hey if you
can fry mean a trillion dollars is
already an astronomical amount that
nobody can even wrap their heads around
so if you can wave a wand and forgive a
trillion dollars you could why can't you
forgive a trillion if you can forgive a
trillion you can literally forgive any
amount you could forgive it a
quadrillion who cares at that point keep
in mind again that college graduates
will statistically make more money not
only that but they're they're also
moving into blue-collar territory and
increasingly taking jobs from group from
blue-collar people despite the fact that
the jobs that they're taking don't
actually necessitate a college degree so
they're taking more money they're taking
jobs they're reaping the benefits of an
education that these working-class
people either weren't able to attain or
chose not to for the sake of being
financially wise and prudent and yet
they the college graduates get the
handout
that doesn't make any sense see this is
the problem that compassion from the
government
it is always is always a double-edged
sword
there's always a loser
there are always many losers in the end
in fact it always ends up that you
create more losers than you had before
and so by canceling student loan debt
you've created a lot of losers in that
situation
all the working-class people
and then not to mention all of the
college graduates who already paid off
their debt and made the financial
sacrifices
all the people who could have gone to
college but chose not to because they
didn't want to pay for it and they did
what they thought was the financially
smart thing all of the people who went
to a less expensive college than they
could have and got a less you know a
less valuable degree than they could
have gotten because they didn't want to
have that debt on their shoulders only
the later find out that oh they might as
well have done it because they don't
have to pay it back anyway you've made
losers out of all of them
all for the sake of making this one
group of people into winners
that doesn't seem just to me and the
objection about well what about the
people who paid off their loans already
yeah this is this is often waved off by
the people who advocate for student loan
forgiveness I don't know how you can
wave it off that's a serious problem
here
because there are a lot of people in
this country who have who made a lot of
financial sacrifices in order to pay
back their student loans
and there's a lot of things that they
could have done and wanted to do but
didn't do so just buy a nicer house buy
a second car so on and so forth they
could have done those things they didn't
do them because they were being
financially responsible and paying back
their debts
and now you're gonna swoop in after the
fact and say oh no you waste it that was
all a big waste you have wasted your
life you know you have wasted years and
years of your life largely structured
around making decisions and sacrifices
so that you could pay back all your
debts you didn't have to do that you're
a sucker
you're a total sucker loser if you can't
see the problem with with with that then
again I don't know what to tell you
it's like your to up to Stu have a
conversation with that is a huge problem
and it seems to me that if we're going
to say you don't have to pay back the
debt then on that same basis and and
with the same logic we need to be giving
refunds to all the people who did pay
back their debts
I don't know how you can get around this
if you have student debt that you signed
on for and now you are entitled to it
being forgiven then yeah I think
everyone who paid it back is entitled to
a refund
for the same reason
so you run into all this part these are
the same kinds of problems that you
would run into if you decided to forgive
all the car payment debt you know
there's a lot of problems there
one of them being among among the many
problems one of them being you know what
about that there are there are people
who go out and buy expensive cars that
they can't afford because they just want
to look cool and they want to have the
latest and greatest thing even though
they can't afford it and they drive that
thing around and then there are other
people who make smart decisions and make
sacrifices and buy cars that are not as
nice and end up immediate needing maybe
a little bit more upkeep but in the end
it's it's it's something that they can
afford
and now you're gonna come in and and
issue blanket forgiveness to all these
people well how is that fair
because the people who made bad
decisions benefit your your-your-your
vindicating their bad decisions
you know there are I don't know if
you've ever gone shopping for a pickup
truck but I've my wife and I have
recently been talking about getting a
pickup truck and it's always the first
time you you know you go online and
start looking up how much a pickup truck
actually costs it there's always a
little bit of a sticker shock because
you think well when you think what is
the most what's the what's the
quintessential blue-collar vehicle you
immediately think pickup truck and so
you're thinking oh I'll pickup trucks
are affordable well you go and you look
new pickup trucks are easily fifty sixty
thousand dollars and you think yourself
who's buying this this is this is you
know these are this is not these aren't
vehicles that are targeted for
millionaires these are vehicles targeted
for blue-collar people and of course I
think a lot of people just say okay well
I got to get something used I'm gonna go
and I'm gonna buy a pickup truck that's
a 2004 model with 150,000 miles on it
and you know if you take care of it you
could probably get it three three
hundred thousand miles and so it's still
worth the investment yet there are
people who make stupid decisions and
they go out and even though they're
they're not making nearly enough money
to afford it they go out and buy a
$60,000 pickup truck should the
government come in and just say oh I you
know what you would forget it you don't
have to pay it back you can keep the
truck too
and all these other people that bought
cars are not as nice now they're
thinking whoa what do I get a nice car
too I could have got the nice car if I
knew you were gonna do this see it's the
same exact problem with the same sort of
problem with college loans so that's why
I'm you know I am NOT really advocating
that we forgive auto loans or or credit
card loans or mortgages or student loans
I'm just saying if you're making that
argument if you're getting into that
world and you're and you're you're and
if we're in that realm now then I think
there's a better argument to be made for
forgiving Steudle the loans of people
who are in the lower social classes but
my solution for anyone who says oh well
what's your solution to this my my
solution is very simple
I say we don't forgive anybody's loans
and it's not like that's easy for me to
say I have loans I'm paying back too so
I'm in the same boat everybody else is
in okay but I say don't forgive my loans
I'm paying I'm paying off my wife
student loans
I've got car loans I've got a mortgage
I've got credit card debt I've got all
that like most people do what I'm saying
is no don't don't forgive that I these
are these are financial commitments that
we made I can pay them back I'm an adult
I can do it I will do it don't forgive
mine don't forgive anybody's the
solution is going forward if we're gonna
stop the bleeding
going forward people have to make better
decisions that's the solution
- car loans if you're being killed by
your car loan well maybe you shouldn't
have bought the forty five thousand
dollar brand new car maybe you should
have done that maybe you should have
gone for the $17,000 used model and when
it comes to student loans as I've been
saying for years there are a lot of
people who are going to college who are
in college right now or who are about to
go to college or who already went who do
not need to go they don't need it
and so that's the solution
it's very simple only people who
actually need to go to college should go
are some jobs where it is definitely
actually necessary to have that
additional education a lot of other jobs
where it isn't necessary at all and then
there are jobs in between where it's
only artificially necessary
where the the market has created an
artificial need for a college degree
like all these blue-collar jobs where
college graduates are coming in and
taking those jobs you don't really need
a college education for that and the
education these people have is
irrelevant to the job but employers are
saying well you know everybody has a
degree so we might as well require it
it's lazy and stupid on the part of
employers but this is what they're doing
and it makes it easier for them because
they don't want to have to actually you
know put any thought into Hatlen to who
they hire and so they come up with these
with these you know with this checklist
for who they're gonna allow in the door
and who they're gonna take seriously
and they you know they they throw the
college degree on there because they
figure yeah you know every most everyone
has one anyway if you don't have one I
don't care about you are they ruling out
a lot of very qualified very skilled
people who would be a great benefit to
their company yes they are but this is
what they do I think
solution is to get away from that
and if you saw a massive decrease in the
number of people who go to college then
this artificial need that's been created
for a college degree in the marketplace
will start to dissipate
but this is a long-term solution it's
not a magic wand it's not a switch that
we're flipping magically and it requires
people to be responsible and make
sacrifices and so of course this is the
solution nobody wants to talk about or
even if you're gonna go to college
there's no reason why you need to right
out of high school jump into the
four-year institution you could take a
couple years you could save up some
money and then you can go to a community
college and transfer the credits over to
a four-year institution after two years
and cut your price cut your costs in
half if not more than that
for almost everyone who goes to college
there's no real reason not to do that
and the only reason why most kids don't
want to do that is because they want to
go to the foreign institution where
their friends are going and they want to
party that whole time
and now we're supposed to pay for that
because you want her to go party I mean
you you could have paid a lot less but
you wanted to pay more so that you could
party and your parents went along with
that because what I don't know they
didn't want the embarrassment of their
kid in a community college they wanted
to brag to their friends about their kid
being you know in the 4-year institution
right out of high school and now the
rest of us have to pay for that nonsense
no I mean that's that's that's the the
like dirty little secret here that isn't
much of a secret why is it but as I said
that there is just no real reason why
kids need to come out of high school and
go right into a four-year institution
there's no good reason for that the only
reason why most kids want that and why
most families want that well for the
kids is because they want a party and
for the parents because of the social
factor they you know they don't want
they'd be embarrassed if their kids
didn't go right to college that's that's
that's the reality
and I think we need to talk about that
when we're painting all these people as
victims we need to remember why they
made some of these choices
all right moving on briefly this is a so
this is this is the kind of this is kind
of related to what we talked about
yesterday with the child-free reddit
thread yesterday there was a there was
also a conversation on social media
about how to talk to kids about abortion
and a woman named Renee Bracy Sherman
offered up this nugget on Twitter she
says I've talked to my five-year-old
niece about my work and and abortion in
an age-appropriate way she understands
that kids are a handful and sometimes
people don't want to be pregnant she
gets it because it's quite simple a
little background by the way on Miss
Sherman
she is a reproductive justice advocate
big scare quotes around reproductive
justice by the way and here's the bio
she offers on her website and I promise
you I'm not making this up
Renae Bracy Sherman is the Beyonce of
abortion storytelling she's a Chicago
born Midwest raised activist writer and
reproductive justice activist activists
committed to the visibility and
representation of people who have had
abortions in the media and pop culture
she is among the most vital voices in
the United States elevating the
conversation about abortion experiences
and using creative and innovative
strategies to shift the conversation
centering people of color and other
marginalized identities her work is so
influential that the right wing website
twitchy recognizes her as the queen of
all abortions so she's a proud of that
she's proud of being the queen of all
boards by the way um Renee that was an
insult you're not that's not it's not a
compliment but the the Beyonce of
abortion storytelling imagine dreaming
up that description for yourself and
then proudly typing it and posting it on
your website and I'm not even sure what
it means because Beyonce is not exactly
revered for her storytelling abilities
when you think about Beyonce you don't
think to yourself wow great storyteller
no you think this is someone revered
because she can dance and lip-sync and
she's attractive that's that's pretty
much it
um but in any event Renee thinks she's
really good at talking about abortion
and it's apparently literally what she
does for a living and this is what she
comes up with she comes up with telling
a five-year-old that abortion is okay
because kids are a handful this is this
is this is what this is her genius the
abortion storytelling genius this is
what she goes with and it goes to show
ironically her attempt to explain it to
a child her attempt to sanitize it for
chub only proves exactly why abortion is
so grotesque and evil
because it really can't be sanitized
this is one of those things there really
is no way to explain it to a child that
doesn't sound horrible this is the best
that this person could do who does it
for a living
talks about abortion for a living this
is the best she could do
and this we it's okay to kill kids
because they're a handful think about
that think about how traumatic that is
to a child think about how the child who
hears that is going to interpret it what
she's being told literally is that if a
kid is a handful you can kill
so it's not hard to think of how a
five-year-old is going to very logically
and justifiably connect those dots
thinkwell wait you know what about when
I'm a handful does that mean you can
kill me
but there is that there's a certain
honesty to it as well which I was
surprised by because Rene here is
basically admitting that you know the
real reason people get abortions most of
the time is that kids are a hassle and
an inconvenience and it's easier to kill
them than care for them that's what
she's admitting and and we know that's
the case
but when you say it like that and you
just put it out there in the open
suddenly it doesn't look so sanitary
anymore all right let's go to emails
Matt wall show at gmail.com Matt wall
show at gmail.com this is from Bobby
says Matt I was hoping you could rule on
something the other day I was walking
down the aisle of the grocery store when
a woman I was passing by dropped her
purse and the contents of said purse
spilled all over the place now I was
right there so they literally spilled
right at my feet but I had a moment of
social panic because on one hand I
wanted to help her pick it up but on the
other hand you never know what a woman
has in her purse and I thought she might
not want me to pick it up because it
might be personal / embarrassing I mean
what if I bent down to help her and the
first thing I grab is a tampon for
example so what I ended up doing was
pretending I didn't notice and I just
walked right by felt like a total jerk
about it but do you understand my
reasoning or will I be executed for this
infraction under your malevolent rule
well Bobby I'm going to exonerate you of
all wrongdoing proving yet again that I
am just and merciful here's my approach
in life in general and by the way I
appreciate the fact that you are someone
who way over analyzes little
sort of meaningless interactions like
that because I'm exactly the same way
and you're able to a split second you're
able to run through this entire
complicated web of logic and then make a
decision whereas I think most people who
aren't like us probably probably most
people just you know they either they
pick down they bend down and pick it up
or they don't but I don't think much
about it
that's not normal people are but you're
not normal neither am i and that's okay
here's my approach in general in life
especially social situations always err
on the side of leaving people alone if
you have to air on one side of the other
err on the side of leaving people alone
so if it's a if it's a toss-up and you
think it might be awkward for her to
help or it might be awkward for her if
you help then don't just like if you
think it might be awkward or intrusive
to strike up small talk with somebody in
an elevator if it kind of looks like
they wouldn't be interested in it or
they want you to leave them alone then
leave them alone if you're gonna hold
the door open for somebody and you
notice that there may be too many paces
away and so if you hold the door open
it'll be that awkward thing where they
have to jog to catch up and they really
would have preferred if you just walk
through and not put them in this
situation if it looks like it might be
that then just keep going don't hold the
door because the minor and momentary
annoyance they might feel about being
ignored by you is a lesser than the
annoyance bordering on panic they'll
feel when they are imposed upon socially
in an unwanted way so that's my that's
my ruling on that now keep in mind
you're getting this advice from an
anti-social recluse who would be
perfectly happy living in the wilderness
and never coming in contact with any
other people aside from his family for
the rest of his life so you know that's
the perspective I'm coming from here but
on the other hand you also know of
course that I have never been wrong
about anything ever in my life so you
also have to weigh that with deciding
whether
trust me or not this is from Lucas says
bruh your your your young person slang
is dead ass lit fam me and my young
person friends were all like this dude
gets us then we skateboarded to the
arcade in our Jing Co jeans Thank You
Lucas for that but bruh I dead ass
suspect that you aren't really a young
person fam reason being you didn't
mention your no fear t-shirt or your
gameboy or the limp Biskit CD and your
disc man so you're way out of touch bro
from Matt says you don't strike me as an
Eminem fan but did you happen to hear
any of the new songs on his surprise
album people on social media are going
nuts for it I did listen to a couple of
them really bad honestly that's my my
honest toupee horrible beats corny
lyrics a flow that sounds like Rob you
know rack rock rap from 1998 speaking of
Limp Bizkit and I just don't think the
guy has the ability to be speaking of
being a storyteller I don't think is the
ability to to tell stories through song
like he used to
and which is which is um sort of
interesting when you see these artists
who just lose their touch almost
overnight and then they don't have it
anymore I think that's what happened to
him a long time ago from Joel says Matt
I'm glad you you came across the vile
disgusting reddit post of the girl
boasting about murdering her twins you
also stated this is representative of
the pro bortion movement I agree a
hundred percent this is exactly why pro
lifers need to stop using the
nonsensical women our victims to line
women who get abortions are not victims
they are murderers they do in fact know
exactly what they're doing and very
often they're excited to do it
they aren't victims they're
orchestrating a conspiracy to commit
murder against their children women who
get abortions deserve to be prosecuted
as murderers well Joel I don't think
you're right about that
I think in many cases you have desperate
often poor often very young women who go
into these abortion clinics and they're
scared
they and they have no one to turn to
their family doesn't you know either
doesn't care or is is pressuring them
often to get the abortion and the father
in many cases is also pressuring in that
direction and so the clinic's take
advantage of them and and take advantage
of their fear and convince them that
they have no choice you know ironically
we're told this is the pro-choice
movement but the abortion industry
survives on the message that you have no
choice the last thing they want a woman
to do is realize that it's a choice you
see which is why on their way into the
clinic if there's a if there are
pro-life there's a pro-life vigil
outside and there's a sidewalk counselor
trying to hand the woman literature
telling her about her other options the
abortion clinic is gonna send out
escorts they call them to sort of be the
lead blocker you know on the way into
the door to stop the woman from even
seeing the literature now if this was
really about choice the abortion clinic
would say yeah read the literature
the abortion clinic would say you know
before you do this there's a there's a
Pregnancy Resource Center right down the
street go talk to them also
you know explore that option have you
thought about adoption if that's if it
was about choice the abortion clinics
would be doing that but they don't
that's why you know Planned Parenthood
they do three hundred plus thousand
abortions every year and they give out
maybe a couple thousand adoption
referrals just so they can say they did
it and that's how they that's how they
operate so they're going to exploit the
woman try to convince her that she has
no choice and they're gonna profit off
of the decision while she has to live
the rest of her life with regret I think
that's how it very often works and in
those cases while the woman is obviously
still responsible for her own decisions
she's not completely morally exonerated
she is nonetheless a victim and I put
the lion's share of the blame on the
snakes in the clinic's the vultures who
are circling around these desperate poor
women waiting to pounce now of course
you do sometimes have women like the one
in that reddit post I shared yesterday
who are cavalier about it and spiteful
and frankly repulsive in their
indifference to their children but I
think they're a minority a definite
minority I mean you said your what was
your phrase exactly you said very often
they're excited to do it that's I can
guarantee you that's not the case that
is not very often the case that is maybe
the case sometimes in a minority of
situations like the one that we that I
shared yesterday my point yesterday is
that the reddit thread is a reflection
of the attitude of the pro-abortion
movement and the industry the end of the
fortune industry tries to instill and
inculcate this attitude in the culture
and in women and as you said yourself I
said it's representative of the movement
I didn't say that this woman's attitude
is representative of most women's
attitudes when they go in to get
abortions because I don't think it is
most of the women who go in to get
abortions are not in the pro-abortion
movement
they are the ones who the movement
targets and preys upon and exploits
and profits off of and yes victimizes
so that's why I put most of the blame on
the abortion clinics and the abortion
industry
and we talk about when we get into
discussion of well if abortion was
illegal you know how are we going to
enforce it are you gonna start putting
people in jail well I would start by
jailing the abortionist
that's my opinion
this is from so we have time for one
more
this is from jr. says hello Matthew how
dare you call me Matthew nobody calls me
that yesterday on your show you
mentioned the importance of listening to
people with different worldviews well I
talked about that was a few days ago you
said on that end you read a Sam Harris
book I've recently realized that I'm
living in a bubble of my own making and
would like to break out of it and engage
with different ideas like you talked
about do you have any other book
recommendations written by people who
are not Christian / conservative I'm
trying to put a reading list together
yeah I do think it's important to to
read widely not just from within your
own worldview but outside of it as well
now what you're talking about I don't
are you asking for books written by
people who are directly confronting and
trying to disprove your worldview or
just by people who are you know from a
different worldview but aren't
necessarily directly confronting you
because that that does two different
things so Sam Harris obviously is
somebody who you know I talked about the
book about free will that he wrote very
very small book now that obviously is if
you're a Christian conservative assuming
you're not a Calvinist he's directly
confronting you and presenting arguments
against your view and I do think it's
good and healthy and necessary for us to
read that stuff and interact with it
engage with it think about it so that we
could be critical thinkers and we can
actually know what the opposing
arguments are
we can't rely on and I think everybody
does this everyone's inclined to do this
must mode should must much of the time I
can't speak we are inclined to you know
what we'll say that oh yeah we've
listened to the opposing arguments but
mostly we listen to people in our own
camp tell us what the opposing arguments
are what we are less inclined to do is
actually go over to another camp and
find the smartest person and say to him
or her tell me what your argument is I
would have hear from you not from
someone over there I think we need to
start doing that and so I would
recommend yeah sam harris i also wrote a
book i have it in my stack over here
well it's over there the book i would i
would most recommend actually over even
over the freewill book is he wrote a
book called the moral landscape and
that's his attempt to rebut the moral
argument for god which i think is one of
the strongest arguments it's also the
argument that atheists tend to struggle
with the most there are some very
barrett bins of very brilliant people on
that side who were very good at
presenting arguments but that's one that
they I don't think ever Christopher
Hitchens is a great example
you know I've watched most of his
debates I've read a couple of his books
he's obviously a brilliant guy a
pleasure to listen to just because
they're so you know witty and insightful
even if I disagree with a lot of what he
says but this this is one that seemed to
trip him up uncharacteristically his his
his effort to rebut the moral argument
for God was always embarrassingly I
think weak so Sam Harris tries to really
give it a go and I I think obviously I
disagree but I think he he does a makes
a valiant effort
so I recommend reading that the moral
landscape again if you're looking for I
mean you could read any Dawkins Hitchens
you know any any of those AC grayling he
wrote a book I forget what it's called
but something like the case against God
or something there's something simple
like that you look up ASA grayling but I
think of all the atheist books that have
been written in the last 20 years that
are just sort of a general case against
religion and I've read many of those
books if not most of them I think a sea
Grayling's is probably the best because
it's very concise and he goes through
each argument and he gives his response
to it and so I would recommend reading
that as well
now if you're looking for maybe books
written by people who aren't Christian
conservative but also aren't necessarily
arguing against you all the time then
you know someone like Steven Pinker I
would recommend he wrote a book called
the language instinct which has a
Christian conservative there's lots in
that that you could easily agree with
and be enlightened by but he's an
atheist I believe
but you know he's not like a militant
atheist trying to disprove you all the
time but he's an interesting thinker at
any rate so that's somebody I would
recommend Steven Pinker he's got other
books too that are that I think are
worth reading who else said Jonathan
Jonathan height is another one another
interesting one even somebody like
Douglas Murray I think he just wrote a
book called the madness of crowds and
certainly not a leftist but also
certainly not a conservative Christian
either so he could be an interesting
person to read no personally I just I am
very bored with people who I'm very
bored with an echo chamber I'm very
bored with people who just give you
talking points and the same old same old
kind of thing so I'm you know as a
reader anyway and as a listener I'm
interested in people who think on their
own and have their own thoughts and
think outside the box as it were so
that's that's what I'm that's what I'm
looking for
I don't need them to have the same
worldview as me in fact a lot of times I
prefer if they don't because I know what
my worldview is I already know that I
don't really need it repeated back to me
I'd like to hear how other people think
and how they sort through issues so I
think it's good that you're doing the
same and so maybe those are some names
that you could start with we will leave
it there though everybody enjoy your
weekend snow or no snow and I'll talk to
you on Monday Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Robin Fenderson the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there